Oh God is Friday and President Trump is
gone after Joe Biden over his latest
campaign misstep this after the 2020
frontrunner had a slip of the tongue in
Iowa we should challenge students in
these schools they have Advanced
Placement programs in these schools we
had this notion that somehow if you're
poor you cannot do it poor kids are just
as bright and just his talents white
kids wealthy the vice president quickly
corrected himself but that didn't stop
President Trump from taking a swipe at
Joe Joe by not playing with a full deck
this is not somebody you can have as
your president but if he got the
nomination I'd be thrilled
oh my god so I don't want get into the
substance let me get into the
superficial so Joe Biden has been known
to mr. you know Mississippi from time to
time it really was a slippery slope but
he quickly gained his footing and got it
right and saved wealthy kids you really
dancing on this one yeah but you know
what he he picked this always slips with
black people remember Obama wasn't
educated articulate lose clean clean
clean
well and what the Democrats already
having a problem not with the black vote
but black voters actually showing up to
the polls even though they may not vote
for Republicans they may stay at home
because the Democratic Party is not
doing a good job to get those votes and
look I'm sorry this is if this is the
best that the Democrats have to go
against Donald Trump it's gonna be a sad
sad I know you're leading this segment
Don but I'll ask you it isn't it true
that so far Joe Biden's been able to
hold the highest amount of support for
african-americans for his support among
african-americans at the Carla Harris
went after him in the first debate his
support almost
double he calm low was she had a
double-digit you know percentage with
black photos after that quote-unquote
interchange Joe Biden support went up
look I don't think this is about taking
anyone for granted because we know that
black voters right now is still with
Democratic Kennedy's what I do believe
is that Joe Biden when he's having these
rips talking about every child deserve a
shot every child this he slips may be he
in his mind he thought white but he was
trying to say wealthy I don't know how
you make that city made it I mean I I
tend to agree with you but I just know
that if a Republican would have done
that I could have been barbecued but his
gaps aren't new he what's new is when he
gets through a thought without a gaffe
there was some other I think one of our
producers has an interesting piece of
tape do we have that let's listen to
this
thank you we choose unity or division we
choose science over fiction I mean that
to me is better than the other kids like
that like you know he's almost I mean
this is the biggest fight of his life
and he's doing it in his eighth decade I
would be really if I was Democratic
Party I would be worried this is early
but Diana do you recall how many gaps at
President Trump made in the last six
weeks of the 2016 election I do except
for I feel like kind of what's happening
with Biden like the people who supported
President Trump it just made them even
more endeared to him and I think that
that happens for Biden as well I guess
the thing is here's what people should
know about Joe Biden he has one of the
best civil rights record of any
politician running today and I say that
out of respect for a lot of people
including Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren Carmel Harrison Corey book etc
the fact is is that he's been on the
front lines fighting civil rights equal
I think I think I think Joe Biden will
become fulness as fine free to rapper
with the disrupt as he said Joe Biden is
the Teddy Ruxpin of gaffes you drop a
quarter and a half comes I remember and
it wasn't even the Obama's clean line it
was awful and I was that he was Reverend
line he was the first African but not
the first black man a woman I've ever
met who was clean in our ticket he was
not
yet if a Republican had said that it
would be over but this is fascinating
your standard here he has a good right
record on so Donald Trump is
historically low black and Latino
unemployment and yet everything Donald
Trump says is a dog whistle Donald
Trump's talking about that's a dog with
no reason wait wait no Trump Donald
Trump lowered flags to half staff on
August 8th numerology guy from the FBI
goes on MSDN C and says this is clearly
a reference to the Aryan Brotherhood in
a prison you're like is this guy insane
so what I don't get is is there a
standard here or not is Joe Biden he
said MS DNC what's that a slim oh that
is what they do they're strong he's he's
good if if he wins the Democratic
nomination we don't know I believe he
will get how is that not a dog whistle
when you say something like hey they're
as smart as the white kids he's saying
poor kids poor he didn't say black kids
he said poor kids you know why well poor
kids this is a he corrected himself he
misspoke he did not say it without Joe
Biden we wouldn't have anything to talk
about on Friday yeah but could I just
make one point the gaps between until
your point about Trump the gaps are
Biden the Trump's gaffes don't seem
related to age whereas Biden and me it
makes it feel like he's slowing he's
slowing down I think that's the concerns
that people might say Trump's gaffes
really like they bring up other
connotations not a